الكلب اللغم اسلوب حربي جديد ربما تستخدمه
روسيا في الحرب في اوكرانيا في مشهد يعيد
للاذهان ما حصل في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بين السوفيات والالماس وفي التفاصيل
مشاهدينا اقترح فيكتور ماكاروف قيادي في
الحزب الشيوعي في روسيا على جيش بلاده
استخدام الحيوانات التي لا مؤالها خصوصا
الكلاب المشرده كمفجرين انتحاريين في
الحرب ضد القوات الاوكرانيه والطريقه التي
سيتم فيها زوج هذه الكلاب في الحرب هي
اولا جمعت تلك الحيوانات المشرده داخل
معسكرات للجيش وتدريبها على حمل المفخات
والمواد المتفجره والرقم بها لمسافات
طويله حتى الوصول للهدف اما الهدف الرئيس
لتلك الكلاب الملاغمه او المنفخه هو
دبابات ومدافع الجيش الاوكراني ما نتابع
هنا حيث تحمل تلك الكلاب استشعارات وبمجرد
ان يلمس الكلب الدبابه او المدفع تنفجر
المفخخات بحملها وهذا بالتحديد ما استخدمه
الجيش السوفياتي ضد القوات الالمانيه في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وكانت وسيله
ومحاوله لدرء زحف الالمان نحو اراضيهم
وكانت الطريق انذاك بتشويع الكلاب ووضع
الطعام لها تحت الدبابات وبالتالي ترويضها
على ان المكان الاول للبحث عن الطعام هو
اسفل الدبابات ثم تحميلها باثنين 10 كلغ
من المتفجرات واطلاقها نحو دبابات الجيش
الالماني وعن نتائجها وفعليتها انساك تقول
التقارير السوفياتيه ان هذه الكلاب استطاع
التدمير 300 دبابه المانيه وسببت مشاكل
كبيره داخل الجيش الالماني وهنا اجبر
الجيش الالماني على اللجوء لاص اوامر
باطلاق النار على الكلاب فور رؤيتها
وحرقها بقاذفه اللهب قبل ان تقترب بالنقاط
او معدات او اسلحه للقوات الالمانيه
[موسيقى]